the college was completely bankrupt in
Chapter 11 and was going out of business
it was desperate and desperate
circumstances make for desperate choices
so I think there was mildly an inverse
parallel between who was most qualified
who was youngest the most qualified
person would have been 16 so I was 23
you know it was a situation of complete
desperation was an anomalous completely
bizarre circumstance it was an artifact
of a strange moment in American history
between the baby boom of the 60s the
civil rights movement the Vietnam War
the draft and all the chaos of the late
60s and early 70s I'm my career as a
function of a random fall out of that
period
how to do the right thing when you don't
have the resources and when everybody is
only interested in becoming a richer you
know i I've lived in an institutional
culture where we measure quality only by
wealth we think a place is good that is
a big endowment we don't care what it
does or whether it contributes to
culture or education in the nation we
have a terrible elementary and secondary
school system bard happens to run to
public high schools has the largest
prison education program in the country
it runs a middle school and teacher
training program in the poorest
agricultural district in California but
it's a very poor institution where all
the rich institutions what are they
doing about public education what are
they doing in the national interest what
they're interested in is their country
clubs they wanna have just a big
endowment so we as a culture have
permitted them to measure quality by
wealth the larger the endowment the
better the place the reason people think
Harvard and Yale or important place is
they're great universities no doubt
about that but what really sticks in
people's mind is it they're rich when
you go to small colleges that don't have
university faculty and research programs
you know they're ranked by third-rate
news magazines primarily by their wealth
not by the quality of what they do
so the toughest job is to go against the
tide to innovate in education in the
arts in areas where universities should
make a contribution you know we have
these international programs in Russia
we're now taking responsibility for the
American diversity in Central Asia we do
a lot of things prisons is a thing where
you know perhaps to some best known for
because it largest college degree
granting program the country why are we
doing that it's creating a culture and
finding people of great quality who are
willing to do that building a college
we're learning and not fraternities and
football and sports and kind of a vulgar
social life is the primary aspect of
undergraduate life the focus on
undergraduate learning running a college
where the
values of Education the love of learning
and public service are a primary aspect
of campus culture that's the hardest
thing to do because you're only measured
by business standards not by quality not
what by what you do but how wealthy you
are so it's as if a hospital were around
the corner and you were a patient and
the hospital said you know I'm not gonna
give you the best training or the best
treatment is because I'm waiting for
three generations from now when a
patient comes in my attitude is
education to be my like a really good
Hospital our primary obligate our
primary obligation is to the patient who
comes in now who's sick was right before
us our obligation is to the students we
have now the faculty we have now doing
the right thing for the country now not
being a bank to protect ourselves so we
still exist for no apparent reason a
hundred years from now
well American Heart occasion is by any
comparative standard more democratic
than any other system of an
industrialized nation so although it
isn't as open and available as it should
be
and the president is very right to try
to press that agenda it is still far
more open and available than in many
other countries with which we often
compare ourselves second it is a very
uneven quality particular on the
undergraduate level but also the
graduate level
that being said by international
standards the American University system
is still in my opinion the very best
system in the world and certainly at the
highest levels of science and research
and scholarship because the American
diversity is structured to foster
innovation and change the European
system is still very hierarchical and
very rigid by comparison so we're a more
flexible and responsive system and we
are I think at the cutting edge of both
scholarship and research the problem is
that American higher education is
underfunded particularly state
universities and I would have wished
that in the stimulus the president would
have done a new land-grant Act would
have really put federal money into all
the state universities directly but the
state universities are in a very tough
circumstance in terms of the ideology I
don't think there's a uniform ideology
there's a tremendous amount of diversity
in the university now the universities
have always had as all institutions have
a kind of weight in one direction or
another but it's very slight what makes
the University really important is that
it's an aggregate of individuals
universities never speak with one voice
you know most people who teach in
universities are deviants I mean who
would be a mathematician average persons
not a mathematician I prefer is not a
physicist every person doesn't worry
about Chaucer doesn't you know study
Chinese literature I mean these these
are you know self selected nuts by and
large no they're not Ozzie and Harriet
they're not your normal neighbor these
are people willing
to spend time in archives studying rare
obscure things or in laboratories
looking at wacky looking fluids in
computer screens these not what people
do to grow up and you know normal people
don't do this and these people are all
trained to think for themselves and have
their own opinion may them do their own
work on science they collaborate but
humanities they write their own books
their own their opinions they quarrel
about interpretations and facts and
histories they're eager to make their
name for themselves in their fields so
the faculty that makes the core of the
university are by definition
self-appointed individuals now they
often belong to schools or an economic
they're group of people think sort of
alike and in political science they're
people think sort of alike and literary
criticism there's schools of thought but
these are schools of thought like fishes
with other schools of thoughts floating
around in one university you have
usually representatives of all of them
and while they might agree in a faculty
meeting on something it's usually
trivial the most important stuff they
don't agree about that's why they teach
their own classes they have their own
graduate students their own research
programs now they may be allied with
other people but often the people that
are lured with are not the same
University there are other university
they have an international community of
scholars so the great thing about a
university is that it doesn't speak with
one voice so all the journalists who
talk about the American academic
community having a left-wing bias or
right-wing by to understand the
university you know it is that most
people are individualís resist any party
membership they're smarter than
everybody who's running for office now
when they make a choice you know there
are two candidates on the ballot so it's
a when I vote I always think I'm making
a choice of the lesser of two evils I
can think of a better way to do it to
begin with so in point of fact the
university is not a political entity
it's an aggregate of individuals
students who come and go and faculty or
by definition non conformists